thank you
[Music]
in some kind of fun news uh Australia's
richest person uh randomly selects 10
employees to each receive a hundred
thousand dollar Christmas bonus that's
tight I know I wanted to bring this up
to inspire you guys because we're at the
end of the year
[Laughter]
poorest company
great way to define it yeah wait that's
that's YouTube's Forest Channel okay
Australia's richest person doesn't make
sense it's all perspectives this guy's
good Australia's richest person oh yeah
how rich is this person so uh this
person's name is Gina Reinhardt she is
actually uh I think her most recent uh
estimated net worth was 28.9 billion USD
according to Forbes as of 2022.
um what she runs is she basically is in
the mining industry out there so her
employees are minors and the way that
she actually decided to do this was to
put all of her employees names into a
hat and literally just pull names out of
a hat that's time 100 Grand well 100
Grand to them is like a dime for us who
feels lucky right now oh wow who feels
[ __ ] lucky right now I got 10 cents
for you guys wait yeah what is wait what
is the difference
yeah one dime to a hundred thousand
dollars
no if they're billionaires yeah that's a
hundred grand is like a dollar oh he's
thinking from the billionaire and I was
thinking from the [ __ ] employees I
like give it to me give it to me
are you saying you're saying that's
dimes to the building yeah that's true
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sure this ain't
[ __ ] yeah but they understand the
perspective they understand the weight
of the dog it's life-changing but still
getting 100K as a Christmas bonus what
company gets that like for example one
of the dudes who got his name pulled out
he had only just started working there
for three months everyone's pissed lose
all the friends in the freaking
workplace yeah dude or he might make new
friends with the other hundred thousand
heirs yeah you know what I mean that's
true now he might stay for life sure
yeah I wish they made an experiment
series out of it to see how long people
could hold on to the money so they say
like if you haven't developed the skills
to make it you don't have the skills to
uh yeah you yeah I mean think about it
like the [ __ ] ain't seen 100K
all the all the time so yeah I think
that's legit how long can someone hold
on I was at a company in my mid-20s yeah
as soon as I got 100 G's I'm probably
gonna buy a 100 G car with it right away
and then at the end of the year they're
like oh you need to pay 30 G's for the
taxes on the 100 G's I'm like what oh
you said I'd be like I didn't know that
and then you had to sell your car so you
could pay your taxes
my card that was 100 is now worth 70 and
I'll pay 30 and I'm left for the [ __ ]
40 or some [ __ ] I don't know please see
you immediately go to buying a car
20s for sure
[Laughter]
how did I get it like I was just [ __ ]
in the parking lot and they're just
sitting right there yeah how do we get
it
um YouTube's poorest [ __ ] company
gives you 100 Grand oh okay [ __ ] what
would you don't look at me I'd buy your
truck dude I buy your [ __ ] truck the
white truck yeah I sell it to you for
100. damn it ah [ __ ] now I got 200. oh I
[ __ ] up my deal
I know I'm gonna be I'm gonna be boring
why what are you gonna do I probably no
I probably travel oh oh that's cool yeah
no it's not yeah where you travel
yeah like what's the top five spot like
is that I would want to go to [ __ ] okay
[Applause]
Alabama no I would probably go uh Sweden
oh uh cause you like white chicks huh is
that like we're gonna tear them up wow
that's uh how you why would you assume
that yeah it's a cheer squad the cheer
squad you know you think I just had just
like you like White Chicks first of all
that's all I can get okay
first of all them Scandinavians are
beautiful yeah beautiful throw that out
I would go yeah Sweden uh Italy I've
never been to Italy oh yeah the foods
are good the best in Europe hands down
all over England pretty much uh uh I'm
trying to think where else do you think
it would blow it all or would you go
like first class five star hotel or
would you like if I had that I would do
first class yeah yeah for a long flight
yeah for a long flight every single trip
would be first class yeah why not yeah
yeah because right now I have to
randomize it and then book my trips like
that so I surprised myself and I go oh I
got business class this time oh really
is business class significantly cheaper
than first class but they're basically
the same some don't have
first class some is just business class
is first class
first class
I heard it's a whole different
experience and then it's like individual
pods I saw Casey nice not take a shower
oh that's like super first Casey neistat
take a shot you watched a man take a
shower yeah he's a vlogger and then he
got a first class was it the United
Emirates flight or something
that was like an apartment and you could
go in the bathroom and you could take a
straight up five minute shower in the
[ __ ] turbulence and then they give
you like a five course meal and [ __ ]
with caviar and all that stuff like for
especially for the Dubai One a shower
and you don't have a seat I think you
have a room you can close the door who's
thinking about taking a shower on a
plane just to be fresh well that's not
white people's [ __ ]
that's that funny but if that water is
anything like the airplane sink it must
yeah it's all dribbling
think about where the water
has anyone has anyone done the the bird
bed bird bath before nah you never done
one where you like had to use the scene
that's just I do it all the time oh you
do it all the time yeah I do it here do
you really here's different on the
airplane that's just way too yeah no I
wouldn't I wouldn't do it on the plane
I'm just talking about in general oh
yeah oh yeah oh you haven't done it
before I Did It For the First Time
recently how'd you feel I feel great it
was not that bad yeah why'd you need to
do it I was I was traveling to do some
shows usually a sign of poverty by the
way
he's all excited by it so actually I
live on the street right over here
no I was traveling to do some shows and
you know I don't know I just felt dirty
after traveling right yeah
and so I I didn't have any time to go to
my hotel I had to go straight to the
venue because the show's like by the
time I got there I only had 30 minutes
till show time oh so I was just like
but but I couldn't look at myself so I
turned off the lights oh my God because
I was too embarrassed because it's just
to look at myself
it's an intimate experience
it's crying about it you did so too then
did you do so yeah because I had my
loofah and I had my myself that I
brought you're a luxurious you're
prepared yeah dude that's pretty good
yeah butt ass naked I grabbed the paper
towel and then I used the hand soap I
turned out and a lot of places don't
have hot water I just do it cold
body yep see I didn't even have time to
get off I just got the important parts
yeah because I because I was about to go
on stage oh you have to be quick yeah so
I just you know
you know you got to get the important
parts otherwise you and I felt so good
going on stage yeah it is nice I was
killing it it was good how's everyone
doing tonight huh
yeah
I couldn't look at myself
now you know you can do it though now I
know I could do it you should try with
the lights on yeah we'll see yeah I'll
see how it feels and then what would you
do with the hundred thousand dollars for
real without buying bars car
I'd probably invest in FTX or something
for reals do like a down payment on the
house for you know yeah for sure
something what's up to you just feeding
him
it's like a [ __ ] it's deflecting
again yeah dude I'd definitely buy a
[ __ ] house dude I put a down payment
in Vegas
probably somewhere cheaper like Hawaii
I'm just kidding now uh because I can't
afford a house in California maybe
because the down payment or you live in
Vegas I live in uh out here oh yeah down
the street in the same box next to you
dude
you don't want to pay to expedite your
black belt
I bet you you can't get a black belt for
100 grand I'll buy 10 [ __ ] black
books especially if the Gym's not doing
so well yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
you want a [ __ ] bike belt here I got
one right here man you know anybody else
that wants a black bear
you bring a friend I'll give you yeah
bring it yeah
freaking friend I love how everything
has to do with me getting up
oh is that an ongoing thing yeah this is
from this [ __ ] yeah cause he'll never
get it
wait how far away are you stuck at brown
belt for like 10 years
he's pretty close hey patience is a
virtue patience is a virtue
but it's hard
I think it's close I have a bunch of
black belts at home and then I have a
mirror and I just put it on I'm like
there's a lineup
so you can't even see yeah yeah
you're black in the dark yeah
yeah boy he puts his brown belt up too
he's like yeah yeah look at me
wow do you ever pose with your belt in
front of the mirror naked to be like
check this out dog what's up and then
sometimes if I feel bold I'll put a red
one on
there's a red belt
are you gonna be the oldest man
it's four it's for jitsu
oh
it's a guy teacher what about coral belt
no no oh I was like he's gonna kick my
[ __ ] ass he would you know why
because he's like six five
okay that [ __ ] is big dude he's
like flipping all these little tiny
Japanese men that he's heavy dude yeah
bro he's a big boy yo shout out to him
he still dyes his hair I'm like bro let
it dude for real it's black you bro
it's blacker than Asian hair yeah
we should get some orange tint
sunglasses what would you do with the
hundred grand I think you got a good
rational but creative mind oh no I don't
know if I'm rational really you would
waste it all
okay I would I would probably have to
have a small portion of it before
absolute dumb fun stuff like cold
watermelon no I'll probably put like a
golf simulator in my spot 50k no no no
they're like 12 Grand or something like
that wow I mean they're so like because
that has like no that's like a that's
like a pure loss there's no like a
financial return on it there's only joy
right yeah everything else has to be a
lot more like reasonable right like
investment style I probably have to give
my parents money because if I was given
like a hundred thousand dollars and I'd
give like 10 000 of my parents that'd be
like if I give ten thousand IPS it's
like them receiving 100 Grand you know
what I'm saying yeah I would at least
have to give them that you're such a
good son I know right only ten thousand
only ten thousand you know because no
one said parents
so that means the money just doubled oh
yeah
she's just doubled up you got a return
already dude
I got the way he says it I only have one
now
[Music]
la la